is a good day for NHS staff who will
benefit from this pay rise and extra
over 5000 pounds for a band Six nurse or
paramedic or Midwife so it's a good day
for NHS staff but it's also a good day
for patients it will allow us to move
forward now the NHS staff Council has
ratified this deal it's been accepted by
the majority of the NHS staff Council
and we can now move forward Focus
together on the patients and also ensure
that staff get the pay rise much sooner
than would have been the case under the
pay-per-view body process there are some
units particularly happy about this
which means strikes will probably keep
going are you going to get background
the negotiating table or is this the
final offer well it is the final offer
and it's important that those unions
recognize the collective decision this
was a decision taken by 14 Health unions
they reached a majority decision it was
negotiated collectively at the RCN were
at the negotiating table indeed Pat
Cullen recommended this deal to her own
members so it's important that everyone
now respects the decision of the NHS
staff council is an opportunity to now
come together there's further areas
where we can work collaboratively in
terms of some of the non-pay issues that
we discussed during the negotiation so
I'm looking forward to working with
Trade union colleagues on those issues
but it's a good day for NHS staff it's a
good day for patients and opportunity
now to get that pay into staff's pay
packets next month and for everyone to
move forward together so this obviously
doesn't include Junior doctors you're
meeting with them later they're far from
Happy do you think you'll get closer to
offer bring them to 35 pay rise that
they're looking for well I think what
the deal with the staff Council shows is
the willingness of the government to
enter into meaningful constructive
negotiations with trade Unions that's
what we've done with the agenda for
change staff covering more than a
million NHS workers we've also listened
to doctors in terms of pension changes
that was a key demand particularly many
consultants that we make changes to
pensions and the chancellor did that in
the budget so we've shown that we're
willing to engage constructively in
meaningful conversations that's
reflected in the really positive
decision today by the NHS staff Council
and I hope we can take that into the
discussions with the junior doctors who
are meeting later today
in number 10. have you got confidence in
Simon case and are you concerned about
what's happened Around Sue Gray's
appointment potentially as labor
Superstar yes I do have confidence in
the cabinet secretary and it's important
that ministers and Senior civil servants
were constructedly together I'm sure
that's the case in number 10 it was when
I was there
Health secretary you appreciate I have
to ask you about this but there have
been claims of bullying around your
behavior in this department we were told
that you didn't know anything about
those uh claims that came out since
those reports have you spoken to staff
around here to get a feeling for why
that may have happened well no
complaints were raised with me but again
it's important that we work
constructively together I hugely value
that the work officials within the
department do and indeed over the course
of the weekend ministers and Senior
officials were working very closely
together both in terms of the staff
Council decision that we've agreed today
but also in terms of Sudan and some
Medics that were in Sudan and other
mitigations in the context of the RCN
strike so we're working constructively
together that's what I'm focused on and
we've got a extremely positive
announcement with the staff Council
decision that's an opportunity now for
the NHS to move forward more than a
million staff will get a pay rise ban
six nurses over five thousand pounds for
the two years so it's a very positive
day for staff it's also a positive day
for patients one very quick one should
the family who were impacted by the
hormone pregnancy test Primitives get
compensation Theresa May and antibina
have both backed it well there is a
court case on that so it's important
that one allows the legal process to
follow its course so you will not expect
ministers to comment on issues that are
before the court but baroness come
Village obviously made a series of
recommendations we've been working our
way through to implement those we've
been taking her reports extremely
seriously but where there's a court case
it's important that that is allowed to
go before the Judiciary and follow the
normal course